lagging oh well well we don't have the
damn thing
i know when we get that thing it'll be
all right
[Laughter]
that needs a little preamble you need to
get the [ __ ] cable
we just pushed the live stick until like
we don't know when it starts so it's
like sometimes we're just like
well we need the [ __ ] thing and the
thing about the thing yeah the thing and
that and her
yeah and there that goes again we need
the [ __ ] thing
turning the [ __ ] thing down on the
thing
yeah like i said because we really
really
i really don't like this lag it's kind
of driving me insane we're gonna fix it
so hopefully i mean i got the cable
so we'll see if that fixes it or not i
don't think he will if it doesn't fix it
then i'm gonna have to buy any laptop
which i'm probably gonna buy a new
laptop anyway yeah like i said i just
i hadn't bought one up to now because i
was like well i'd really like to have
another mac laptop but i sure as [ __ ]
cannot afford a new mac laptop
yeah this one that i'm this one that
we're streaming on right now is from
2008
you guys it's good enough for what
you're doing it's good enough for what
i'm doing but
not enough for streaming i'll just have
to get like a dedicated
pc one we'll go down to sam's and go get
one
yeah they have some like nice ones hey
everybody everybody popping into the
how are you guys doing it's monday yeah
getting some [ __ ] done today well i'm
getting some [ __ ] done i always get [ __ ]
done
every day
mango badgers on i can't believe you
guys have not got like bored of us
already and you just
oh my goodness here it goes she's the
door squeaking
she's like what do you do yeah she
throws the door open like she it's like
walking into a saloon in a western
we should get her a little cowgirl
outfit yeah that's exactly what she
needs oh my gosh that would be really
funny yeah she [ __ ] throws the door
open
she's like how dare you close the door
yeah i have boxes in here that i have to
sniff yeah
[Laughter]
well she knows that i just brought in
packages to see what kids she wants to
smell
it's the same thing every day she
[ __ ] knows she knows
when we wake up she knows about
showering and going into the [ __ ]
closet because she wants to play when
you come out the shower when you get
dressed
she knows about when mail shows up she
knows about dinner time she knows when
we eat she knows when she's supposed to
eat
when lights turn on and when they're
supposed to turn off and when the doors
are gonna get locked
she knows all that [ __ ] oh yeah she
knows the routine
oh yeah she's very good and we've got
her now because she'll go out and
like outside at in the evening she
doesn't go out during the day really she
likes to kind of like sleep most of the
day
but when she goes out in the evenings
and she mostly just stays on the back
porch or the front porch
and just kind of watches everybody go by
or chases lizards or whatever
but she knows that like once it's like
10 o'clock at night
and she comes in and the outside back
porch light goes off and a little collar
comes off that's a wrap then that's a
wrap she stops asking to go out
because if yeah if you leave the light
on she'll like scratch and be like
what the [ __ ] this isn't fair yeah it's
still open it's still open
yeah it still is but if you turn the
outside light off and take her
off she's like oh okay yeah you can see
her like slump up yeah
it's all over it's over no more outside
today
i don't have to wait till it's hilarious
yeah that's hilarious
and she's real smart and she'll go right
to an area where she knows you're gonna
be that's the next thing in the process
yeah yeah it's [ __ ] ridiculous oh i
forgot to tell you i saw beijing do the
funniest thing today
i was in the laundry room like putting
the putting a load of laundry in and
that's where the litter box that's where
beijing's litter box is
so beijing comes in and uses the litter
box
and then she like jumped right out of it
and ran out of the out of the laundry
room
but then like five seconds later she
came back and
and then she reached her arm in and like
scooped over
and then scooped some underneath the
[ __ ]
the [ __ ] she buried it yeah but it's
like it was funny because she didn't do
that
yeah it's like she took off and she's
like oh [ __ ] i forgot to like very
bury my pee and so she came back in and
just she didn't climb back in she just
stuck her arm in the side it was like
[Laughter]
and then she had spilled some out of the
side and then she stuck that like
underneath because the um she tried to
hide that she tried to hide it she like
pushed it under her house like what the
hell yeah i gotta go in there with a
broom in a [ __ ] dustpan and [ __ ]
sweep up well she has like a lot of fur
she tracks [ __ ] kitty litter
everywhere so yeah she's like has really
long hair so i feel like
you know she's not real but she at least
knows that it's not supposed to be
outside of the thing because she like
she tried to sweep it underneath the
we're talking about shelving
[ __ ] tv well that's okay this is what
always happens
we were just you know well we got on the
cat because cookie just walked in
we got regulars listening to us before
all we know we got some random
[ __ ]
six months from now going through
youtube trying to find the damn review
of this movie
and they gotta hear us talk about
[ __ ] cats in the cat box come on
everybody loves cats
yeah the name of this movie was called
host yeah now this is very confusing
because this is not
the korean monster movie called the host
which came out i don't even remember
when that came out like
to mid to late 2000s i don't know which
was also excellent
also there is another movie that came
out this year
that might be on netflix that's also
called the host and it's like a thriller
this is not that one this is a horror
movie this is a shutter
original now this is a movie
okay so this you guys created
creative people it just goes to show you
that like
when life gives you coving you make
covenant lemonade whatever it makes you
do something you take like so shitty
situation
and you do something with that this is a
movie speaking of coping
man i feel swallowed bro he's got the
corona no i swallowed that damn
this movie was made during the pandemic
they were first yeah
and it was made entirely over
zoom yeah and it you know what i mean so
like the movie
it's not it's not made to look like it
was made over zoom it actually was made
over zoom yeah it looks like you're
just looking at watching it on your
laptop yeah you're watching the youtube
stream
and like i said this is not the first
time that they've done something like
this it's a good idea
um you know they've done like unfriended
they did uh there was one with elijah
wood called open windows which i think
was pretty much all took place like on
uh various computers and cameras and
stuff
so it's kind of like a found footage
type of thing but
i don't know as far as i know this might
be the only one that was actually made
over zoom like the whole thing yeah it
actually had good acting
the acting was very good they really
sold it they had a couple of little
uh little little spots of [ __ ]
special effects
and uh you know like [ __ ]
i guess you could say he's kind of like
[ __ ] the ghost grabbing people by the
throat and pick him up that kind of
stuff kind of paranormal activity type
stuff
yeah um story was pretty good
it was it was a very modern story it's
just like you're watching a damn
a a live stream with a bunch of [ __ ]
people
on it trying to do a seance basically
yeah i mean if the
that's essentially like the two word
pitch
for this is zoom seance yeah is
basically what this is
so you have like a group of six friends
um
almost all of them are girls one of them
is a guy but he's like kind of
taps out early but then he comes back
later and they decide while they're all
in quarantine
and i guess some of them are in other
countries because it sounds like a
couple of them are american
um the woman that's running the seance
like the medium woman she sounds irish
um and then like a couple of the other
ones are brits or australians like i
couldn't quite tell like a couple of
them it's an international
cast it's an international cast and i
didn't know this until i like looked up
another review of it
but all of the characters in there
that was their real names like they were
they were playing themselves essentially
um so and i don't know if those were
their real houses i'm assuming they were
because everybody was in lockdown so
they said hey you know we'll just
make a movie make a movie and we'll just
film now it's not like um
this was written and directed by rob
savage now he's a cinematographer i had
heard
his name before um i think he's only
made
like short films up to this point but so
i guess this is his first
it's not quite feature length because
it's only about an hour long
but i don't think it really needed to be
any longer like i said like i said
before
them trying to force an hour and a half
worth of
worth of entertainment inside of a small
[ __ ] low budget story
it's not worth the risk it's really not
it's better just to make it as long as
you can make it with the story that you
have
because it's better to have an
interesting one hour than a [ __ ]
boring hour and a half
yeah and so i think that was a really
good choice and we've said this a few
times before where it's like if you
don't have enough story just make the
movie as long as it needs to be
you know don't add like a half hour of
[ __ ] in there that nobody cares
about
now let me ask you this is this cinema
is this a movie does it feel like a
movie no
it doesn't really it doesn't really feel
like a movie to me
is it good though yeah it's all right
it's pretty good i actually quite
enjoyed it like i said it's not
super original they've done like other
like i said like unfriended or friend
requests they've done like other movies
like this
and there was another one that i think i
watched it on i think
netflix that's called open windows
elijah wood was in it it was more of a
thriller
than horror but it's i believe it was
done entirely through
uh you know the computer just other yeah
you know windows and like uh you know
security cameras and things
so it's like that it's not like
completely original and the premise of
it isn't completely
it's very simple um basically just these
six friends they're bored
they decide they're gonna get together
the one of them
uh haley i guess she's talked to this um
medium before named salem and she wants
and she's done like um
seances before with this woman and so
they decide they're gonna do
one and it goes pretty much as you would
expect if you decided to do like an
online social distance
seance with your friends like the
friends are kind of like
thinking it's all [ __ ] or it's just
like a lark or whatever
they're they're doing like a couple of
them are coming up with like drinking
games like hey every time the medium
says astral plane like take a drink but
have to like pretend that they're not
because
they don't you know they don't want to
like be disrespectful and stuff so it's
like
really funny and they they're pretty
quick in the way that
they kind of get all these friendships
established
i don't know if all the people that were
in this movie like
knew each other prior to this because
they really do
it really does come across like just a
bunch of friends
who decided to to live streams to live
stream
a seance it doesn't seem like actors it
doesn't seem like i mean i'm sure it is
but it doesn't seem like that mango
badgers bringing up some good stuff
i was gonna say that well he's saying
the same thing i'm saying you're
probably gonna see more of these
yeah because they're easy to do and
they're they're they're cheap
if you don't have any money you can make
a movie like this it's kind of like bear
witch project yes
like that now you probably won't be able
to get away with it for very long
because there'll be eventually be too
many of them
yeah but for the time being you can make
a movie like this and get away with it
yeah and i'm sure this was like totally
not all that expensive to make
i mean although i will say that the
special effects that they have in there
because
you know everyone's just farting around
not taking it super seriously at first
but then over the course of the hour
like
[ __ ] starts ramping up um to a point
where people are seeing things hearing
things in the background like not
really knowing what's going on and they
i think they did a really good job like
pacing it you know what i mean where
it's just like building up the
and there's like some scenes in this
that are like really really creepy where
like some of the people are like
you know going around their apartment
they hear something in the background
everybody's like go see what that is you
know what i mean
it's a logical conclusion this is the
logical conclusion to the technological
situation
right now yeah blair witch project
came out [ __ ] made the found footage
[ __ ]
genre well this is the live stream genre
yeah you're not watching a movie you're
not finding footage
you're at home watching some people live
stream some [ __ ]
and the paranormal stuff happens and
there's a story it's an hour worth of
entertainment like you witnessed
some paranormal [ __ ] over the livestream
over a live stream yeah that's exactly
what this is like and that's that's a
good idea it is
they won't be able to get away with that
for a long time no but this one was the
first one i've seen that that come up
with that
yeah now there have been
ghost stories and paranormal [ __ ]
movies that have happened
deer during supposed youtube channel
filming
yeah that's not the same as watching it
happen over youtube yeah
that's what this one this one is like
you're watching it happen over a
streaming service
it's almost kind of like i was gonna say
it's almost kind of like some of those
like weird like arg
like youtube channels like the alternate
reality games where
they're put where people supposedly are
putting
paranormal videos up like this should
happen to them but it's really like a
fictional story but it's supposed to be
real
so it's kind of like that and in fact i
don't know
like you said uh it's not technically
found footage because
no one found any footage no this is
almost yeah it's almost more toward a
mockumentary
yeah type of thing than found footage
right i think found footage gets too
judiciously
or too like widely applied you know what
i mean
yeah people just say that's found
footage but it's not but sometimes it's
not i mean
blair witch project is obviously the way
this is found footage movie the way this
movie seemed to me now
maybe i wasn't keeping track of the
point of view
all the time but it seemed to me it was
a first person movie
like you're watching it happen on your
own laptop yeah
like you were in the meeting like you're
in the stream right like you you've
logged in like you're watching a damn
youtube live stream yeah
and there's a bunch of people uh what do
you call it when there's a whole bunch
of them in the live stream um
i forgot what that function well yeah it
was not well it was basically not one
person live stream and it's a bunch of
people live streaming and you can see
them all like when you have guests yeah
well this one well they didn't do this
on youtube they did it on
zoom they did it there's a zoom meeting
yeah which essentially is the same thing
you're live streaming but they
they use it companies use it like yeah
you know for larger
you can do it on youtube too yeah you
should yeah you can you have little
screens everywhere
yeah and you see people talking to each
other across the internet
that's that yeah and then paranormal
[ __ ] is happening to some of them
and i really like i like the way they
did the paranormal stuff in this it does
it is very much
like you know the paranormal activity
movies i don't know hold on one second
i don't ever remember it going third
person it never went to any of those
locations like you were there did it
it was just like you were watching it on
the screen yeah yeah
you never go to one of any of those well
yeah because they didn't
shoot it they shot it exactly the way
you see it
right yeah they had each actor yeah hey
let's
do a zoom meeting and then they edited
together point of view the camera never
changes it's just like you're watching
it happen on your screen like yeah
yeah that's the way i remembered it yeah
that's exactly the way it was it never
changed any point of view
no yeah okay and honestly there was a
point i think there was a point where
one of the characters
um because i'm not sure like how far
apart some of the characters were
because like i said some of them had
different accents so i
assumed they were like in different
countries or whatever but one of the
characters
was worried about one of the other
characters and apparently lived close
enough that she could
run outside and like go to the other
person's house yeah you know what i mean
um but everybody was filming stuff now
like i said
if you're gonna be a stickler about um
you know why would anyone film that why
would you go back in your
um you know why would you go up in your
attic if you heard a noise out there why
would you take your phone with you why
would you do this on the other if you're
going to be like
then you know you don't need to be a
butthole about that then
yeah then why are you even watching
horror movies period because no horror
movie ever would have happened
if somebody didn't go investigate like
some scary [ __ ]
they're behind you no don't do it no
it didn't bother me in this though
because i feel like well in a couple of
the people that were um
i think at least one of the women that
was in the live stream
her boyfriend was supposed to be there
so she had heard a noise and she was
like wondering where he was
at you know what i mean so she would go
thinking someone else was in her house
and i think one of the other people like
their dad was in the house or something
so it's not like totally crazy to think
if they heard a noise they wouldn't go
hey
because they thought that it was like a
live person
but you know what i think all the
[ __ ]
crazy stupid [ __ ] horror movies tropes
used where they were all through the 80s
and [ __ ]
how you knew what was gonna happen you
know
just because you knew the [ __ ] genre
well that's the thing and like i said
particularly slash you know like you
can't
because you go like well you know that
guy's black he's going to die
and that was remember that for a long
time he was always the first
person to die well they they even like
lampshaded that they like made a joke
out of that
like in later like more meta horror
movies because it was true it happened
all the time the black guy was like one
of the first ones to die first one to
get killed
that's why when i saw the that's why
when i [ __ ] saw the thing man i was a
[ __ ] i i thought the thing was awesome
because
the black dude made it to the very end
yeah
yeah it's night of the living dead that
was probably yeah
but it was just kurt russell and keith
david and they never really showed
who who was going to die next yeah you
know so yeah he ran it all the way
to the end yeah let's go to sleep i mean
i assume they both died but you know i
had i
assumed that uh kurt russell toast
flamed him
i kind of feel like probably because
remember he passes it he passed him the
uh the [ __ ] bottle of whiskey
yeah and that was like in the beginning
he pours whiskey into the [ __ ]
computer that he's playing chess against
yes [ __ ] you [ __ ] so he cheated by
destroying the
computer yeah and the next time you see
him with whiskey he's giving whiskey to
the very last guy so i was thinking that
he was gonna
that five minutes after the credits
rolled he just went
right because you know [ __ ] you bro
you're the thing
[Laughter]
i'm not the thing and i don't know about
you so i'm just gonna toast your ass
kurt russell was [ __ ] that was the
thing about kurt russell is kind of
funny
because because uh [ __ ] uh what what
was that character's name
wasn't it mccready yeah no i'm not
talking to him talk about the um
uh keith davis's [ __ ] character
forget was it child's
no yeah i thought that was the same
child's i think it was
child's try to take over and [ __ ]
kurt russell goes
no no no no no no no i think we need
somebody who's a little more
even-tempered a [ __ ] child's like
yeah okay i see how the white boy wants
to play this
and then kurt russell was [ __ ] even
tempered no he wasn't even tempered he
was like i know i'm not the thing
[ __ ] all y'all i'm gonna find out which
one of you guys are yeah he was one of
the least even tempered people yeah he
wasn't even typically
they were they were all pretty they were
erratic but the thing about it is that
the situation
yeah there was a desperate situation
that was yeah i mean anybody would yeah
it's like a funny that's cool though
right but that that movie for me as a
kid watching that in the theater
that totally changed the game that the
[ __ ]
the the that that the black guy made it
to the very end that he was
you know what i mean yeah because
normally they died you really didn't see
that no
i mean it was good writing and carpenter
did some cool [ __ ] with that
yeah it's just funny that you know and i
can't think of anything like offhand
because i'm sure there have been horror
movies that
you know ones where people end up in a
situation
that they can't get out of and they
didn't do anything stupid or they didn't
do anything to deserve it because i mean
slasher movies
you constantly had teenagers being like
hey
let's go to this creepy abandoned place
and then we'll hear something outside
and we'll go out by ourselves in our
underwear to see what the [ __ ]
noise was which no one in real life
would ever do
why would anyone do that nobody would so
it's like but you just have to like
give it a thing and this one really
didn't strike me as too egregious in
that regard because
i mean they were you know the characters
at first they were kind of like
[ __ ] around and like they didn't
really think anything was gonna happen
but then like it ramped up so slowly
that
i could see if you were into doing the
seance and if you
kind of wanted like paranormal [ __ ] to
happen
that you would do some of the [ __ ] that
they did
and i mean the thing about it too is
that if you're home by yourself and
you're talking to other people on zoom
or whatever
and you hear something in the back i
mean probably you should go check that
out because it might be a murderer
so you probably need to know that so you
can like call the cops or whatever yeah
so
you know i'm not i'm just saying um
so it didn't strike me as like i didn't
think anybody did anything
intensely stupid in the movie is what
i'm saying yeah well it's a movie
yeah i don't i don't [ __ ] look at it
that way
[Laughter]
because a lot of stupid [ __ ] happens in
[ __ ] movies you know what i mean well
yeah
like i said a lot of horrors i'm trying
to show you so it wouldn't even happen
unless people made really stupid
decisions yeah um
not so much anymore because i think you
can't really get away with it to
that much of an extent because everybody
knows like all you all get away with it
but you have to kind of lampoon it
yeah that's the only way you can is you
have to be like self-aware about the
[ __ ]
duck man [ __ ]
cinema is a [ __ ] an art form that's
been around for a long time it's now
kind of like the epic
poetry or the or poetry reading of the
[ __ ]
20th in the 21st century
everything's been done it's true and
uh it's true it's very hard to innovate
and come up with something good nowadays
you kind of have to stick with [ __ ] that
worked
and a lot of these directors and all
these [ __ ] studios don't really
necessarily want to stick with
what works and so it ends up not really
entertaining the crowd all the time you
have to be able to entertain the crowd
and get people [ __ ] to watch
but it's real hard to compete against
video games you know
and it's real hard to compete against
classic [ __ ] movies that have been
were made a long time ago like
like the dang it predator wanted
terminator you know not only did they
come out at the right time they're just
good stories they're they're fun to
watch
yeah and if you redo them and change
some [ __ ] around and make them new it's
gonna piss off the [ __ ] fans you know
like you don't remake there's certain
things you don't remake
yeah and the thing is there's so many
other stories you could tell
like original stories and like i said
there's even a lot of [ __ ] books you
could adapt if you don't want to come up
with your own story
or you could just do a variation on that
but do your own [ __ ] with it
because like you said everything's been
done right but that doesn't mean that
you have to come up with something like
completely different
you could have something like yeah and
you gotta be careful
not to stay away from certain tropes
because they think that they're lame
like
the chosen one trope they hate that you
don't see that anymore
okay but that makes a good karate movie
that makes it you know like and [ __ ]
that's also in star wars when you think
about it but evidently a lot of writers
and a lot of
directors hate that they because they
think that's so played out
well yeah because i mean look at like
harry potter and look at like oh you
know
it's been done so just because the
writers don't like it doesn't mean the
audiences don't like it audiences
respond to it
especially young ones because they kind
of be able to put themselves into that
yeah because they feel special yeah like
young kids want to feel they
so they identify with characters that
feel special oh they're talking about me
you know like a lot of why a still has
that that's that's the name of the game
oh
my connection is unstable so now it is
unstable
oh it's headed up there and said my
condition i never had that happen
we have an unstable connection oh no
i just myself that we should start like
flapping around like that like they do
on star trek you know
yeah like we started waving around like
we got an earthquake
mega said other than a psychic he hated
every character but he did enjoy seeing
i liked all the characters i don't you
know they they were inoffensive um i was
indifferent i was you know they seemed
they you know they didn't do a lot of
like
character building or back or anything
but that's okay i mean they were
perfectly
i'm fine characters i'm 51 years old i
was not the target market
or the target audience for this for this
[ __ ] movie you know it's just
i think that you know this would have
been if i was 20 i'd like
this movie i think yeah and i thought it
was you know like i said it was not
super original but the acting was really
good like i said i i bought
into it that these were all like real
people that they were all like friends
with each other that were just
doing this just [ __ ] around and you
know they did a good job of like
building up like slowly building up the
creepy [ __ ]
and some of the imagery in it was like
really creepy i thought like especially
i think the best thing in it was
that one woman that got like pulled up
and
in the air and stuff like that i thought
that was really cool and apparently like
a lot of the
um a lot of the stunt work was like real
stunt work it wasn't like
um so you know they had a lot of
practical effects which i thought was
cool there was like some cgi in there
too obviously
yeah but um you know apparently a lot of
it was practical so that's always good
to see
but yeah this is i mean if you have an
hour to kill and you just want to see
something creepy that's kind of like
paranormal activity but you know
set now like set during the quarantine
and
yeah you know that just like is a whole
like thing that happened over zoom
then i you know i i thought it was fun
i thought it was a good time mango with
badger saying he still wonders at the
end of the thing if [ __ ] keith david
was the thing i think he was
i think he did i think so too but i like
that they left it ambiguous
i'd have to go back and look because i
think keith david
and i think his think that character's
name was childs
was i think his name was childs i think
he had an earring
you might be able to check and sing was
in yeah did he have an earring or like
um any
fillings or anything yeah because
looking back on the shot i remember
keith david turning his head
to the to the left when he took before
he was offered the drake
it could have been looking back on it
that maybe his earring wasn't there
which is why i can't remember but i see
well that's the thing
because when they did the prequel thank
you man
thank you very much when they did the
prequel
um there was a scene like that where she
was in the
in the um the snow cat or whatever like
with the guy
and she saw that he didn't have an
earring anymore so you might want to go
back and check real quick
so i don't know if you were thinking of
that maybe maybe i'm thinking of that
but you might want to double check and
see if he had his earring in
because they might have been hitting to
that
i remember noticing that certain people
had changed their clothing before they
[ __ ] changed into
the thing [ __ ] you know crusoe says
you know yeah
tears through your clothes dear when it
takes you over well yes it's like
if you watch some of them are wearing
different clothing
and then they ended up being the thing
you'd have to go through it backwards
i guess and keep [ __ ] seeing looking
what seeing who is the thing
who's got earrings who's got different
clothes on i guarantee you that was that
was carpenter's best movie
he did no he did know who the thing was
at any time in that movie
it wasn't random well you would have to
the thing was i mean that would be
something that because if you just like
were just like [ __ ] whatever and
didn't think about it then it would just
especially nowadays everybody would pick
holes all the way through it
yeah but after that man if i became like
a
after seeing that movie i became a big
[ __ ] crustal fan
and [ __ ] keith david too man you know
what he showed up in a lot of good [ __ ]
he wasn't a lot of guys he's doing a lot
of good [ __ ] his voice you know the way
he projected himself
you know i remember him in and they live
yeah that was [ __ ] really good he's
fighting rowdy right at piper
he was a good character in that he was
uh they interviewed
they interviewed him in uh in search of
darkness too the one that
documentary we talked about yesterday he
is also delightful yeah
he's awesome yeah he's awesome dude rick
shaw says not gonna lie paranormal
activity made me poop
it did have like little scary bits this
reminded me
a little bit of that like a couple of
the scenes in it were paranormal
activity yes
but there's nothing wrong with that
because the first paranormal activity
was really good
i didn't see any of the sequels although
i think all of the sequels are on
2b like i don't even remember how many
sequels there were maybe five or six of
them
um and i've heard they were trash but i
don't know
maybe they're okay it's making me want
to go back and see the thing
right now well we have it oh yeah i got
it you can watch it there's
three of them on my mind there's three
of them [ __ ] with me right now
[ __ ] it they're [ __ ] with me dang has
been [ __ ] with me
demolition man's been [ __ ] with me i
want to see that one again
and i want to see if i can escape from
new york again i gotta get back on that
one i've seen that one for [ __ ] 15
times 20 times
yeah we've seen that movie lost and
escape from l.a khan is growing on me
kind of growing on me i don't know if i
i don't know if it'll ever grow on me
it's kind of growing on me it's it's
just i just look at it a little bit it
just kind of makes it go it's like a
parody
you know it is yeah it's like a parody
of it um
i think there's another one i think it's
called lockdown isn't it the one what's
his name where he goes to [ __ ] mars
that's like escape from earth yeah yeah
yeah yeah what was that guy's name
uh he's got this did the machinist right
yeah
uh what's the guy's name god damn that
makes me want to watch the machinist
that's on 2b actually yeah that was a
[ __ ] up game
i can't remember why why are you i don't
know i don't know it doesn't matter
rickshaw also said christine is
underrated i agree yeah good movie
and it's like nobody ever and that was
another good thing that we forgot to
mention about in search of darkness they
did actually talk about that movie and
how
yeah and i've forgotten because i saw it
so many times when i was growing up and
then like we watched it
not too long ago when we reviewed it and
i was like god damn i forgot how good
this one yeah i got to get that one in
my uh
carpenter i love that movie also keith
gordon was [ __ ] great
yeah dead zone and fire starter got to
get those those that was
yeah we did a review of the dead zone we
haven't done fire starter yet though i
don't think that's a good movie did we
review fire starter
i don't think we did we did the dead
zone and we did christine
was fire starter uh also carpenter no
he was originally supposed to do it
right but then
he went off to work on another movie or
he got fired from it or i can't remember
like what happened
he was initially going to do it because
of the dead zone or no dead zone was
cronenberg
um but yeah john carpenter was initially
and
john carpenter did christine yeah but he
was supposed to do fire starter too but
then they ended up somebody else ended
up doing it the brood was [ __ ] with
me too i want to see the brood again
yeah i love that movie that's a weird
movie rebecca dunn says we should do
silver bullet
i love that i like that one i i only
vaguely remember that one
that one had [ __ ] ah gary b
gary busey before he was totally crazy
he's still pretty crazy in it but he's
not like you know
homeless bum behind yeah sleeping on
people's couches
right he wasn't that yeah he was still
pretty young but he was he's like a
super fun character corey haim was in it
yeah um that was actually based on cycle
of the werewolf which i think
that was a graphic novel i remember
checking that out of the library when i
was a kid
yeah and it was like a comic book and i
don't think it i don't know if it was
available in any other
format i thought that was the only
format i ever saw
uh for that one but yeah i feel like the
the book was a lot darker
than the movie the movie was almost kind
of like funny
but also pretty fun yeah
and i'm not a huge fan of werewolf
movies but that was like a really good
werewolf movie
better than maximum overdrive right
maximum overdrive
is you've never seen it never seen it
i've just seen clips of it i've never
seen it
never [ __ ] see that it's based on a
short story called trucks
um which is like a serious story but
um stephen king was filled with all of
the cocaine
yeah and decided that he was going to
make i don't even know if he intended to
make a comedy
but he did yeah but it's it's one of
those movies that's like
that's just terrible but it is wildly
entertaining
it is at the same time you would
probably love it really
you would probably love it i mean dude
you get to see like a little kid
get run over by like a [ __ ] what the
hell are those things called where they
flatten out the steamroller
yeah steamroller there you go little kid
gets run over by a steamroller
guy gets hit in the [ __ ] nuts with
the cane like coming out of the [ __ ]
vending machine
i think i remember that i think i saw it
it's got the woman that does
bart simpson's voice and like she has
like the most or mar
uh lisa simpson's boys rather and she's
got like the yearly smith her name
is and she's got like she's like the
world's most annoying character
[ __ ] emilio estevez is in it ac dc
is like blasting through the whole movie
it's
delightful it's delightful you would
imagine
i didn't really like the language i
didn't like language either that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
no see the langoliers was not this was
nothing like the langoliers i mean the
because the langoliers seemed like it
was just i don't know it was it was very
meh yeah and like i don't know i had cg
yeah it was just like me i just didn't
really like it but
um maximum overdrive is like
it's like wrestling it's like you know
what i mean it's like it's like watching
wrestling
like it's really big and loud and stupid
but it is also super super fun okay so
you would probably really really love it
i kind of feel like you would
in the comments section they're saying
it's [ __ ] a joke it is it's bad it's
a bad bad movie
but i always like i always found it
really entertaining like how bad it
is it's just one of those like so shitty
it's good
yeah you know what i mean all right all
right so uh that'll probably do it for
this
review i think tonight
i found another like new one that i
wanted to watch that sounds
super fun so uh want to watch that and i
also want to watch the old one that
we're going to review so we can record a
review for that but like i said i'm not
going to say what it is
unless you're a patreon unless then you
probably already know but yeah so uh so
we'll see you guys again tomorrow
probably same bat time same bat channel
uh so we'll see you then like share
subscribe
yeah do all that bye